[Music]
theoretical physicists have been
fighting against each other for the last
20 years and the fight is only getting
louder and louder now they're actually
insulting each other on Twitter which is
the maximum you know that's the highest
at the peak of academic performance why
is that well because string theory which
is supposed to be the next round of
fundamental theories it turns out that
physicists have known for a while that
both quantum mechanics and general
relativity which are the big the big
ones in the moment in the field and
actually incomplete and indeed more than
that they actually give contradictory
results when they are applied to the
same kind of problems like the physics
of black holes for instance so we know
that there must be something else some
other theory that it's actually
encompasses both or overcomes both or
whatever the big candidates in the field
for a long time for decades has been
string theory which essentially says
that the most fundamental things in the
universe are not works but these
vibrating strings that vibrate at
different frequencies and the frequency
makes them appear like a quark or an
electron or whatever it is great it's a
beautiful theory mathematical incredibly
complicated because it builds on quantum
mechanics which is already the most
complicated mathematical theory we have
unfortunately for string theorists we
have zero evidence empirically speaking
that the theory is correct it does
explain everything we already know but
you know that's easy
probably speaking so it doesn't
contradict anything that we know but it
hasn't made any new predictions that I
actually fed empirically testable okay
so a lot of other physicists are getting
increasingly nervous about this thing
and say you know you guys need to stop
doing this and do something else because
this is not paying off it's possible
that we're looking at an interesting
evolution in theoretical physics where
either physicists are gonna change the
standards by which they actually test
their theories and accept their theories
or the field might split into a couple
different components with different
notions of what it counts as a
scientific theory there would be a big
development we'll see I'll get back to
you in 20 years for more debates talks
and interviews subscribe today
to the Institute's of Arts and ideas at
IAI TV
you